so when you ask people to stay at home
not to go out as a country you have to
be ready to support these individuals
because they need to go out every day to
earn their living
[Music]
togo a western african nation sandwiched
between ghana and benin
it's home to about eight million people
where the average income is below two
dollars a day so what we did is that
within
less than 10 days uh the team within the
ministry of digital transformation
built a platform which is a mobile
payment platform and so this platform is
very innovative because first of all it
didn't require people to have an
internet connection all they needed was
a basic phone and they would register to
the platform through their basic phone
so from registering onto the platform to
receiving cash took less than two
minutes and we were able to give people
approximately one third of the minimum
wage
and in total we spent 34 million dollars
to 920 000 to go lease individuals
so there are two things number one i
have to tell you that the privacy
questions were mostly asked by countries
and individuals in europe and in the us
in togo it was not the case because at
the end of the day we were able to
distribute free cash and so to the
poorest police these individuals weren't
too concerned about privacy but as a
responsible government what we did was
that we had a consent form when you
register onto the platform
you have to give your consent that your
data is going to be used within this wc
program but what we're also doing right
now is that we're working with some
startups in various places to find ways
to anonymize the data that we collect
so that it's not linked to a particular
individual going forward what is
technology like novici fintech like this
how do you see it revolutionize the
continent of africa you mentioned how
it's working in togo right now but how
do you see it pushing forward across the
continent novici is a mass payment
platform so anywhere it is implemented
enables whomever is operating the
platform in this case the government to
pay out large number of population in
togo we were able to pay 25 percent of
all togolese adults which is 920 000
individuals
but now we're using it to pay nurses who
are in charge of administering provine
vaccines throughout the country it's a
very effective
way very quick way to pay out people to
make sure that they get the money in
time so it's been used as a mobile
payment platform for large numbers of
people
[Music]
you